many Americans are planning a trip
overseas according to AAA international
travel bookings are up more than 200
percent over last year and if you're one
of those planning to go abroad make sure
your passport is up to date otherwise
you may be putting off that trip CBS
News Transportation correspondent Chris
Van Cleave reports on the big backlog in
passport processing
Mitchell corderone thought she was ahead
of the game booking her family's
European Vacation months in advance I
found a good airfare deal and
um then I was looking through our
passports and realized oh wait uh the
boys passports expired now a growing
backlog of passport applications has
their June trip in Jeopardy current wait
times are as long as 13 weeks that's
more than three months you know you
think that if you get started with a
process in March that you that would be
enough time to get your passport by June
and I'm I'm hoping that that's true but
I am a little nervous
long lines are popping up at passport
offices across the country ahead of
what's expected to be a record-breaking
summer travel season they said the only
other option was to go to another
location which is in LA
not going to go to LA the state
department issued nearly 22 million
passports last year a record high
current demand is up at least 30 percent
as 500 000 applications a week keep
rolling in despite an increase in
funding and more staff wait times
continue to grow I have a task force
established at headquarters to Marshal
all of these efforts so that we're
really digging in on this we were
authorizing overtime we've opened
satellite offices that's just not good
you're you know the government's going
to disappoint people airline industry
analyst Henry hartevelt it's not just
alarming it's embarrassing I know people
have been waiting three four months to
get their passports fulfilled and even
if your passport doesn't expire until
2024 you need to think about planning
ahead because many countries require
that your passport be valid for up to
six months beyond your date of Entry
it's
frustrating because it why does it have
to be so convoluted for now the quarter
owns are hoping this passport problem
doesn't postpone their summer vacation
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Chris Van
Cleave in Los Angeles